Did you think the latest MCU film was
all about the Wakandans and Talokans?
Tucked into the corner of the movie screen
were some easter eggs you may have missed,
which hint at what a certain
pint-size hero may be up to.
Black Panther: Wakanda Forever closes
out Phase 4 of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe with perhaps the studio's most
emotional outing. The film follows the
great people of Wakanda after
the tragic death of T'Challa.
Wakanda Forever begins with Shuri racing
against the clock to save her brother from
an unspecified illness. Despite her efforts,
T'Challa dies and leaves this world to be
with his ancestors. Much of the movie is
then set a year after T'Challa's death,
showing Shuri's continued study of technology and
science while she struggles with her grief. While
the film's overall storyline pays tribute to
Boseman and his MCU legacy, the plot does work
to intertwine Black Panther: Wakanda Forever with
the MCU's overarching story plan. Marvel is known
for intricately weaving its films together,
and there's one very important Easter egg that
fans are spotting, and it's all in preparation
for the MCU's next highly anticipated release.
Snippets of CNN newscasts are sprinkled
throughout the film. The clips show Anderson
Cooper giving news that helps to propel the
story forward. And sharp-eyed viewers are
noticing a nod to another Marvel superhero
while Cooper reports the news of the day.
In the Marvel Studios
subreddit, one Redditor wrote,
"Did anyone catch Scott Lang is writing a memoir
on the CNN news scroll? I got
a good chuckle out of that."
A fellow Reddit user replied,
"'Look Out for the Little Guy'!!"
This seems to be the title
for Scott's upcoming memoir.
Scott Lang is known to the world as the superhero
Ant-Man and first appeared in his 2015 solo flick.
Lang is an ex-con who's recruited to break
into a house hours after he's released from
jail. During the break-in, Scott finds the
Ant-Man suit created by scientist Dr. Hank
Pym. The suit allows Scott to communicate with
ants and make dramatic changes to his height.
And Scott's book detailing his journey from
ex-con to superhero isn't the only big news
that fans are noticing on the bottom of the big
screen. One Redditor believes they saw mention
of an autobiography tour while another
posted about Scott's potential podcast.
Of course, references to Scott are all
in anticipation for Ant-Man and the Wasp:
Quantumania. This will be the third movie
centered around Ant-Man, and it's the initial
installment in Phase 5 in the MCU. The first
trailer – released just a few weeks before the
premiere of Black Panther: Wakanda Forever
– shows Scott basking in his superhero fame
and enjoying life after coming back from the
blip. But he is called back into action when
his daughter Cassie creates a satellite that sends
a signal into the Quantum Realm. Janet Van Dyne,
who spent decades trapped inside the Quantum
Realm, warns Cassie of sending such a signal.
But it appears her warning is not heeded as the
trailer shows Scott, Cassie, and the Pyms digging
deeper into the Quantum Realm. They will also
face Kang the Conqueror, and it's a face-off
that director Peyton Reed is looking forward
to. Reed recently told Entertainment Weekly,
"I grew up reading the comics and I knew
the character of Kang the Conqueror,
who's one of the big, big
bad characters in the comics,
so to be able to put up our heroes against
Kang the Conqueror was a huge thing for us."
“So what’s it going to be… Ant-Man?”
Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania flies
onto the big screen on February 17th, 2023.